i'm not very emotional but i think one
of the saddest
cinematic scenes he always laughs at
this
is when [ __ ] dave chappelle is
roasting nutty professor
that [ __ ] is the saddest [ __ ] to me
because i never like bullies you know i
don't like seeing people
like who cares every time he said i
laugh
i was like that's the sad thing man i've
been to
funerals
that [ __ ] is so when you look at the
look on his face and then play the music
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast we have recurring guests
actually you guys haven't been on this
podcast in a hot second a second i don't
think i've ever been on it i think it
was me
so many [ __ ] members that's why and i
only have two seats so i always have to
like do lottery and [ __ ] like who's
coming on it's like the parent is like
uh you know
yeah you know which one i'm talking to
you know in high school i had a friend
she had i think she had a total of nine
siblings
by the time the last kid hit was like
their only boy child
they didn't even name him his name was
just boy i'm not even [ __ ] lying
like for how long forever his name's
still boy name is
boy
so when they used to call him like hey
boy come here i'm like yo call him by
his
yeah yeah that is his name why
why i don't know i think they just got
tired after number eight
they said you know i boy let a family
member name them
no sibling name them boys i thought they
were just being super disrespectful
they're still disrespecting me that's
very difficult
adlib
[Laughter]
um so we oh go ahead first thing we want
to talk about
all these damn peacocks a lot of
peacocks nbc in here
[ __ ] talk we
not only is it a peacock he was standing
brolic on the fence like
what's up he's like okay one peacock we
get to stop saying look left is a
peacock
there's one right there we go to turn we
gotta stop it's another peacock crossing
the street i'm like
yo i didn't know that there was this so
when we first moved into this area
the uh whatever the [ __ ] person that
rents out home
what do you call those people the real
early yeah the realtor yeah i'm an adult
[ __ ] you
so she came up she was like oh there's a
lot of peacock as if that was a selling
point and i'm like that's not a selling
deal yeah i don't know
big ass chickens yeah these things
they're
they're everywhere like the other day
there was literally so
this is how peacocks work there's the
male right and they're actually called
uh somebody corrected me in the
neighborhood they're like they're
actually not peacocks
cox what are they called they're called
like p
hens or some [ __ ] like that oh no
females are called p hens and the males
are called peacocks but they're called p
foul so this is this is the type of old
people conversations yeah
david's going downhill guys he's over
here
talking about peacock species and so
apparently like i don't know like 60 or
70 years back some rich [ __ ] brought
these peacocks
and with this weather in southern
california they just started multiplying
but they're not indigenous to their the
area they're like southeast asian birds
or indian birds are they aggressive
they are aggressive so like those bro
they're
known to see if you like just wash your
car they'll see their reflection in the
[ __ ]
of your car and they'll [ __ ] your car up
so that's crazy
because if you notice like with with
peacocks they only roll with one dude
and he pimps out like seven birds
so it's always one guy the one with the
big feathers that just pimps out like
six or six yeah
the one that we looked at to the left it
was it was him
but then i seen like two little two
little uh yeah those are the females
oh yeah and so you'll always see them
roughly around like six or seven o'clock
they scream it sounds like a
seven-year-old dying
and then they'll scream they scream i i
[ __ ] you'll probably
hear scary [ __ ] they scream and they
bring out their feathers
and they get reception and they
literally rotate like this like a
satellite
so they can get [ __ ] and then you'll
see like six girls walk up to him so do
you think the ceo
nbc lived in arcadia
he said i gotta create something i gotta
get the [ __ ] up out of here but use the
peacock
but it's a it's a cra it's a big ass
bird i was like if that's just sitting
at your window you'll be [ __ ] scared
i remember my friend in arcadia called
me one day and she was like
i don't want to get out of my car there
are two peacocks outside my door
i said let me tell you something i don't
know the temperament of peacock so i
would stay in your car too yeah i don't
i don't know what the [ __ ] they gonna be
on when you get out of there so i signed
up to the the neighborhood app here
right
just so i could hear other old people
i'm [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah i was talking to the neighborhood
and i wasn't supposed to laugh at this
but people put up their own personal
problems [ __ ] i don't know i don't know
what
what's with like people who own homes
they kind of vent on their neighborhood
yeah but then he was saying she was like
can you guys please
pray for my chihuahua because they got
attacked by peacock
they probably only have a couple of days
to live bro i laughed
oh yeah because that's not something you
hear everything i'm not
oh like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that's why i looked up how
aggressive they are apparently they're
that's an issue for me because me and
rome do walks in the neighborhood that's
our old trade yeah yeah
i'm doing walking saturday morning we'd
be walking yeah yeah and there's no
peacock so i would be scared
a little scared about that like all
right if he down there it's like seeing
a loose dog i don't know what's gonna
happen let me just go another way funny
story we
so you know how some people um
they'll something that happened to them
on a street or something and they'll be
like you know what i'm
not gonna let that bother me i'm gonna
conquer that fear i'm going back on that
street
not happening yeah we one time was
walking on this one street
and this dog i guess it was two dogs
there's two dogs and there's one i guess
he was the leader of the dog and he
jumped up on like the thing and so you
can see his body kind of halfway over
the fence like
if he wanted to jump off and come after
he could but he stood there and looked
at us
we've never been down the street again
that was a month ago
how often do you guys i started walking
like three or four years ago yeah we've
been walking for a minute yeah beautiful
[ __ ]
it's therapeutic yeah you get it you get
it
judge me [ __ ] walking around you guys
still got good knees
i had a tour meniscus that walk feels
good man you're like man i'm looking at
the neighborhood i'm telling you me and
my boy khalif there was a certain point
where he and i were walking
eight miles a day that's when pandemic
hit and just gleeful when i looked like
uh
you've been in one of your skits yeah
that looks like uh uh
the knee took the knee
and we found this trail out over here uh
in pasadena
it's like apparently like all everybody
does that trail i didn't know about this
because i was living in south pasadena
at the time for like four years i just
never went outside my room so i didn't
know
i didn't [ __ ] know so i just once i
started realizing i could explore this
[ __ ] city
we found this trail and from where we
start to end it's like
four miles there four miles back it's
eight miles total
and we were doing that [ __ ] because we
had nothing to do and then we started
realizing like
literally we would be out all day we
would come back and our day was over
and my feet would be throbbing yeah but
it was cathartic
it feels good like we would just you
look up and don't even realize how far
you walk yeah that's the thing and then
they say that they
it's all these like healing practices to
walk in and all that stuff
like well besides just the health part
of it but just like mentally it's just
especially during the pain
do you feel like you guys got more like
aware of yourself during pandemic
because i think a lot of people i was
talking about this earlier
that like pandemic kind of either made
made you better or it ruined you
for sure i felt like it was a big reset
for everybody i felt like everyone even
the earth needed it yeah
they speak about like the you know
environment but it needed it like when
you look outside in l.a it would be so
much small
they're pandemic i was seeing stuff like
wait it's a mountain yeah
it's funny i think me and him so we're
born 16 days apart
this is crazy so we have this synergy
birthday april 17th oh [ __ ] march 30th
we're all aries
oh come on that doesn't seem that
interesting
yeah we get it mentally
i would say stronger than a lot of the
average person so a lot don't
bother me and stuff that do bother me i
can get over it quickly so my whole
thing with the pandemic was come out on
top
take advantage of it and that's why we
started the shades line and i was
reading more
and i was like i just want to be the
best version of me so i'd start working
out i started walking more
i think we were already in it but i
think i feel like it just
boosted it like especially after we read
the book i think we talked about on the
last podcast the 5 a.m club like
it just kind of boosted it from there
like we were already reading and stuff
like that but once the end of pandemic
and stuff was going on then when i read
that book
it was like oh okay yeah it's time to
really like really lock in and say
yeah i i'm gonna i haven't read a book
in like 10 years you got to read a book
you got to read a book damn [ __ ] you
gotta read it i haven't
so i used to have a problem with reading
i used to read books all the time yeah i
just get my ass because i used to read
too much because i wouldn't i wouldn't
sleep that's why you're not reading
right
well i picked up a guitar i found out
[ __ ] good targets you're more [ __ ]
than a book
so like i literally started playing
trying to do music but i haven't read a
book in like damn you 10 years every
time
i've i've opened up save the cat how to
write a script 10 years haven't finished
it what about audio books i meant [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
i listen to podcasts
but for me it was the opposite when i
was younger reading was a punishment i
don't want to
play video games my dad like all right
y'all been playing read a book so i
looked at books like a punishment until
i got older and i was like finds things
i like to read like i put an intention
on
2014 when we moved to the i don't know
if you ever has he been to the old house
i feel like he might have came out at
once but he was the two story yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that house i like i don't
want a tv in my room i want to read as
many books i can in a year i read about
15 books a year and the first two was
the four agreements
which is the book i always recommend and
um
the alchemist which i read in one day
never did that again that's how good it
was i couldn't stop
and those two books changed my life
but i see how it's changed me my
perspective that's why i feel like i'm
more mentally strong because i'm
always reading and always using my brain
and getting new information
i can implement in my life damn dude i
ain't [ __ ]
like i i literally refuse sometimes when
i start reading books i get angry
i'm like yo tell me how to live my
[ __ ] life angry
yeah i get hella mad all these [ __ ]
when i watch it though like so i'll do
self-help one month and maybe business
then maybe like uh
an adventure or some or autobiography so
it ain't like self-help self-help
because you gotta you know
so much information i'm trying to i
really do feel like i kind of thought
about this the other day because
sometimes when we do these college shows
these kids ask me about what they should
do with their life and i'm like yo you
don't ask me
i've been getting lucky for 10 years
dude i'm surprised i still have a living
don't ask me i'm just i'm figuring it
out yeah you know you're successful what
did you do i was like don't follow me
kids
i don't know god has just blessed me and
we just did a podcast on our boss
talking about going with the flow like
the lesson i learned recently is like
letting go control and just
because if i feel like the universe and
everything is in my favor why am i
trying to control every outcome that's
like the aspect of fear in a way
i'm scared of what it might be if i
don't control it so that's what you were
doing you was just going with the flow
and living in that space and you've been
blessed because of it
and ever since i started doing that some
blessings you feel like your spiritual
life helped it too
like like just like helped you kind of
like your faith helped you just continue
this because
it's easy to give up in what we do you
know what i'm saying you know what it is
man like i've i've talked about this a
lot too it's just
uh and i've had an issue with people
actually one of the things that i
realized in pandemic
uh i've already cut off a lot of people
out of my circle
i cut it down even more during pendant
and one of the one of the things that i
really disliked and is because of what
pandemic
did to other people i don't like people
who aren't grateful
so if you don't have this idea of being
gracious for the things that you have
i can't [ __ ] with you so that might have
to deal with you know
growing up in a church it's always about
being grateful about you know these
small little blessings right
when when pandemic happened a lot of
people came i started hearing a lot of
complaints about stupid [ __ ]
right and like i talk about this too
where you know first world problems are
very real but they're very real
depending on who you say it to mm-hmm
because you can't talk about your first
world problems to people who are
struggling it's in proximity
and people don't understand that so like
i like somebody i recently had to cut
off is because no matter how good this
person's life is
this person complains
a lot and you know had a conversation
with him and i was like bro i know what
your life was like
10 years ago yeah the fact that you
could still complain when you have all
this
blows my mind like i i can't hear it
because it
starts to affect me because i that's the
thing too like i just never complained
and i think that's always allowed me to
go with the flow because
i remember when i first came to la i
bought this desk at walmart
i had this imac that i put my whole
savings into i sold every [ __ ] jordan
i had
just so i could buy a camera all this
equipment lenses and whatever
and before i came here all my friends
from sacramento they
before i left they pulled in this money
to buy me this 2470 lens which is what i
needed to shoot stuff
right i remember that [ __ ] till this day
and it makes me grateful for the things
that i have so
when somebody tries to bring that
negative energy into my life
i just go [ __ ] you because i don't need
this no so when people talk about like
okay so what are your goals in life it's
like to be honest with you i've kind of
exceeded what
everything that i wanted now
everything's a bonus so it's about
being grateful for the things i have so
that's the kind of perspective that i've
always had
every time i leveled up with something
i'm like yo i can't believe i get to do
this yeah yeah yeah when i went on set
i didn't realize how much people asked
for things i was like that dude
because i was casted for this netflix
food show and they
they were they were like what do you
want on your writer i'm like what's a
writer they're like
it's like snacks and food i was like
just give me beef jerky and water
this person literally said to me it's
like this is not a bulgarian prison
you want snacks i'm like nah just give
me like beef jerky
that's literally how we are a long time
ago you know a story about a long time
ago
oh long time ago we had to do this show
and they asked us did we need anything
okay now i know and we literally was
just like
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends for those of you
who don't know skillshare
is an online learning community that
offers membership
with a whole bunch of meaning now i have
a lot of hobbies a lot of side hustles a
lot of things that i'm interested in but
i don't want to scour the web
looking for random people to teach me
stuff that i don't even know if they're
credible
or in the position to teach me these
things well skillshare
has a bevy a huge database of online
instructions to help you
get to where you want to be no matter if
it's a hobby
no matter if it's a side job or whatever
you want to learn skillshare
just might have it for you i mean think
about it what do you want to learn you
want to learn
uh after effects you want to learn how
to organize your life you want to learn
i don't know gardening something out
there skillshare will probably have it
for you man
and so far everything that i've wanted
to learn or i was curious about
skillshare had a course for it currently
right now the course that i'm taking has
nothing to do with my hustles at all
it has everything to do with the fact
that during pandemic i needed to learn
how to take care of my plants so i'm
actually doing a course called indoor
gardening with ekta chadri
and i gotta tell you there's so much
stuff i didn't know about this but my
plants be
brimming with live sun so for all my
genius brain listeners out there explore
your creativity at skillshare.com
brain and get a one month free trial of
premium membership that's one month
of a premium membership at
skillshare.com
brain uh we can just have some some
water that i mean that's that's fine we
don't need
pretty much maybe some chairs yeah
after we did the show kind of find out
they said we were on a high horse
we just wanted water like that that's a
basic nutrition
for water in a chair because well we was
hosting the trey songz uh
uh show at georgia state and he was late
and we didn't have to we kept the crowd
going yeah we had to do that performing
things
and we kept the show going until he got
there which was like two hours late
and they said we were on our high horse
we weren't getting paid for this
we didn't we was doing this just for the
exposure out of love with this you know
it's still early you know early in doing
this like you know two years after maybe
water is life that's what that's in
chairs chairs
so we can use them to act on our house
fancy [ __ ] asking for [ __ ]
sustenance
but we've always and but what's i was
just talking about this yesterday with a
patent to hear i was just like why
is it that us as creators once we work
and we get to a certain point
we're still afraid to like ask for
certain things sometimes because we
don't want to come off
as oh they they want to but we should be
able to after you don't work a certain
amount of time it's like
yeah i would like this and this and this
but then
the other part of you was like you know
what it is i bet you it's because
every single one of us growing up when
we would ask for things we get our
[ __ ]
don't ask for [ __ ] when you go on this
stream yeah
i can't believe you asked for water and
they're like baffled us
it was crazy anything you say something
to do i'm like i'll [ __ ] kill you
i think we just let it go we just never
did anything with that with the
particular organization again i don't
think because we're just like all right
well they don't appreciate just
and why the [ __ ] was trey song so
[ __ ] late come on man
arnold is just
and then he said he didn't want us to
introduce him yeah we were the host
he told his people to come tell us not
to introduce him we were like oh
okay all right oh you just think cause
you slang an eight-pound dick you can
just do whatever you want
the most shocking video i've ever seen
in my life this was around the ready era
right yeah
it is what it is but yeah i feel like we
should be able to celebrate your
luxuries like when you
when you get to a certain point you're
just like all right i don't want to
clean no more i'mma hire somebody to
clean
that shouldn't be looked at is like oh
you lazy it's like nah i just i got
other [ __ ] to do it's a time thing
it's hard because like it's not stuff
that you know i don't think we grew up
with yeah
yeah we cleaned the household we had to
do this stuff yeah but
it's weird because now i'm learning how
to prioritize time a little bit more
right
so recently listen i i do this thing
where i [ __ ]
i get into something really deep for no
[ __ ] reason just because i have
insomnia i can't sleep like except books
i'll send you some books so i can read
it watch watching two years david still
gonna have a book
i'll write a book yeah i want to thank
cam in rome
i didn't read a book but i wrote one now
read my [ __ ] i'm definitely reading that
book
but i had a [ __ ] um so i got super
deep into cleaning cars
so okay so i got i i'm in this house now
right we're renting this house
and i have a garage and a driveway and a
hose i haven't had a hose and
got damn near i don't know how long you
know because apartments you got home
yeah yeah
yeah and so i was like yo i'm i'm gonna
wash my [ __ ] car i haven't washed my
own car in a hot second
i got so deep into this i spent 400 on
car cleaning [ __ ]
and then i was like because i'm gonna
save money four hundred dollars
right yeah that took me four hours to
clean my car
the biggest waste of time yeah it cost
to clean your car i washed my car two
times a year the [ __ ] was i thinking
it's gonna take me damn near seven years
to get my money back oh yeah there's a
wrap on that
you might as well that's in the red all
those peacocks gonna be dead but
you guys have a book on a smart
investment yeah don't don't buy
washing equipment that you don't need
that's funny that's funny though so did
you you so you watched it once
but why was it so much thing it was like
cause you were waxing waxing and
detailing it's just all this you guys
need your car wash too i need to make my
money back
bro david in the middle of michael pull
up like what the [ __ ] is david
watch the car bro i just need to make
sure this is my money's worth
it's hard work yeah no you guys are
sweating like
it's it's rough my god and then like i
didn't realize
like how dirty a car is because you know
other people have been watching my cars
and you know sometimes they take a
little longer like
lazy [ __ ] you ain't getting no
goddamn tip i'm tipping so well now oh
yeah
i mean you tip better now that you've
seen it hard i mean i always tip well
i'm gonna tip a little more now because
it is hard [ __ ] yeah and plus i didn't
realize that when you put on wax if
you're not paying attention you forget
where you put the wax
so i'm just like oh what happened [ __ ]
[ __ ] i had to re-wipe the whole car down
i was pissed
and it actually really started because
my neighbor
his name is david as well he watches his
car every two weeks
and then he saw me bring in people to
wash my car and i think he kind of
lightweight
judged me a little bit so i'm like hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
i watched my car i watched my car better
than you so you felt guilty
you assumed that he assumed and then you
was like i need to go ahead i assume
right because i know that [ __ ]
because he washes his he washes his car
with the with a regular hose
i bought a pressure washer oh you
weren't playing i don't know i was like
[ __ ] you it's not funny y'all capita's
neighbors he come out and see that did
he come back with something
oh yeah and both of the lives are
looking at each other they got a whole
car wash
like [ __ ] a store out there for
people to come through
in the neighborhood that's coming in the
driveway [ __ ] neighborhood
fundraisers and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm better than
that that's funny i feel like but
as adults we dive into just things
especially creators we like to just
do [ __ ] i feel like we just like the
like over the pandemic i was like
you know what i wanna i wanna study how
to be a sommelier
for wine and [ __ ] so i just started
looking you know about wine a little bit
i took like one hour class and i was
like oh yeah i know my [ __ ] now i don't
know [ __ ]
i don't i don't know anything mine is so
[ __ ]
stupid i'll tell you you know why it's
this is this is why i say stupid i have
a friend who
loves wines and i just asked him
straight up i was like when you talk
about this [ __ ] right
you're bullshitting half the time he
goes most people are he goes when you
drink wine just drink the [ __ ] that you
like
yeah that's it all that matters you like
this drink it because i can give you
like a thousand
dollar bottle of wine yeah you'll drink
it and you'll probably hate it and you
but in your mind you'll be like oh i
taste the notes
of rosemary because i started doing food
and i started realizing how
people are just full of [ __ ] like
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they talk about things as if they're an
expert in in the realm just because they
want to sound smart
and that's what people do about what i'm
not talking about people who are wine
connoisseurs and they
they're sommeliers or whatever
sommeliers i don't even know how to say
like they know what's up but like think
about this um
sturgeon caviar right i see gordon
ramsay he
you know he puts it on his [ __ ] the
back of his hand like a little [ __ ]
because he puts on the back of handcuffs
because somebody said you have to put it
on the back of your hand
the idea of this is very stupid yeah
they do it they eat it he goes
this is the most amazing thing i ever
had in my life this
i've had caviar yeah it's salted water
eggs
i know it tastes good it has something
to it yeah that's the best thing you've
ever had
truffle right i like the way truffle
tastes like truffle fries like chopped
fries
our fire right and people talk about it
as if like oh you need to have truffle
like it's the
it's worth its money okay i get it it
tastes good but it's the best thing
you've ever had
shut the [ __ ] up it's because there's a
certain status that comes with it
you know food because you like truffle
you know food because you like caviar
the weirdest thing when people get into
food on when they get into these things
is like
you shouldn't let somebody dictate to
you what tastes good when it comes to
food
you like it that's fine yeah one of the
best food i had was a sausage from the
corner store oh yeah atlanta
something small sausage sandwich we were
going there them ships with fire
exhaust and nobody could tell you
otherwise that that tastes good to you
right and people love doing that they go
oh when people started getting into food
because food culture is really big
yeah like i i own food spots right and
then i ate
at mcdonald's they're like you still eat
mcdonald's like yeah [ __ ] i still
[ __ ] eat mcdonald's it tastes good to
me like what are you talking about well
i don't i mean i eat
the sausage egg mcmuffin i like that i
know that you're living
do you think it's a conversational piece
though because i think like i mean we
were talking about one day like
it's cool to be the guy that knows like
all the hot spots in town for
restaurants like somebody asked you and
like oh yeah you go to here
try this on the menu it kind of feels
cool
so i think that's kind of the same thing
like with wines and [ __ ] like that
people be like oh yeah i do it yes it's
maybe i'll be bullshitting but it's a
conversation to be if it sounds
like you're axed and not always
volunteering gotcha okay yeah yeah
someone asks you like hey you like wine
then you spit your [ __ ] yeah
but if you just come like you sit down
well you know why you know doesn't
matter that's when people don't [ __ ] bro
i'll [ __ ] with people up though i'll
[ __ ] and they'll [ __ ] with me
it's like bro i don't know what i'm
talking you lying through your [ __ ]
teeth right now
i'm like yo this wine right here it
comes from the area of genovese
a lot a little dryer a little drier on
the palate than i expected
but you know what it's it's actually
pretty nice yeah i heard the summers are
really good too and they'll be like yeah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i don't know why i made
all this [ __ ]
it's two buck chuck [ __ ] you would
respect it more than they said man what
the [ __ ] you talking
exactly the funny thing i'm not a big
drinker like that but i recently my
homegirl brought over a wine cheap wine
the best one i've ever had in my life
and i took a picture of it hold on let
me
it'd be funny if it's a cheap wine
i don't even got a label
does your lady drink yo she drinks not
as much
okay but then uh typical i've been
drinking a lot because of pandemic no
for sure
drinking drinking [ __ ] and drugs went
up during the
day all that just weed everything went
up yeah
like i drinked that i drank yeah cause i
started getting really into uh tequila
because yeah me too yeah cheap ass wine
blueberry flavor it almost tastes like
juice that [ __ ] was amazing
hey man wrong with little stella rosa
dude take a picture of it
i don't know i like that you know how
i'm not old this [ __ ] photo didn't
change
that [ __ ] let me tell you that [ __ ] was
so funny
it ain't what you would think they was
going to look like isn't it oh
he got them old hands always you know
when you're handing him a phone he
accidentally pressed up
[Laughter]
you got them old hands oh it's just like
melted snickers bars they just
wipe across their ashes
hard is fun
that's funny
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
hey can i just read this title real
quick though yeah go ahead it's just the
title to this
it says that nbc's ultimate slip and
slide
holds production after explosive
diarrhea outbreak on set
wait wait wait after explosive diarrhea
explosive diarrhea outbreak about a
hundred people
got shitty ass that's terrible
come on man come on
[ __ ] that had me dying so if you guys
don't know i was on their podcast and
[ __ ] emmanuel
picked up the phone like it was a ham
sandwich
change the whole [ __ ] phone he went
into his nose turn on the flashlight
and he called your mom something sorry
hey parents grab [ __ ] parents and
toddlers just grab
[ __ ] i was i think i was dying laughing
for like two days straight that [ __ ] is
funny man i think what
i didn't even pick this up when i was
watching the clip like it's like when
emmanuel
uh flipped the picture he went oh
he's always been like y'all too he's
always been an old soul
is he like the one in the group that's
like uh is that my f well i'm gonna
continue
yeah yeah he's the one in the group
that's like gonna come out in the robe
that's
not gonna go to the party or if he does
go to the party he's gonna leave early
yeah he's that guy he says he's gonna uh
show up at the party but then he's not
at the party he's not at the party
and we tell him you ain't coming what
you mean i ain't coming you know he
don't
stop trying to just go to bed i mean
it's always there's always that one
person like that like i
i don't go out as much as i used to like
when i was because when i first moved to
la i was
in k-town for like five years straight
and so
every [ __ ] day we went out we i had
uh
me and my buddy ed so ed won this
competition for this uh korean alcohol
called soju
so soju we had a year's supply of it oh
i had some soldiers did we
listen fashion story i'll tell you my
soldier story
but basically we killed that whole
supply like in three or four months oh
year supply
well everybody came into our apartment
like it was the place to be yeah and we
had to get rid of this alcohol because
it was taking up a whole room
so like just come through and just drink
yeah this girl that was in town from
like germany or some one time was like
yeah come this spot meet me at uh
this korean barbecue i was like well i
can't eat any barbecue really and it was
like well
just just come hang out so i came and
then they brought out this shoes like
you ever had soju
and i was like uh no um what is that and
it was like oh it's like a alcoholic
all right cool and she they brought out
they ordered like 10 bottles so i'm
getting like
oh this must be like lightweight cool
bro we went through them bottles
i was smacked i was like
what the [ __ ] is in here like i was like
oh i don't need to
she was like oh yeah i should have told
you slow down on the soldier oh now you
think so now
that's just it was good though it's good
that almost this podcast is brought to
you by vivino my friends can i tell you
right now
that when vivino approached me for this
podcast sponsorship i was hyped because
i actually have been using the vino for
quite a while
anytime i purchase wine online i
typically go
to vivino and the reason why is because
the buying experience of their wine
is so easy for somebody like me who
doesn't really know what they're buying
now i've talked about wines before and
i'm not that knowledgeable about it but
you actually don't have to be if you
purchase your wines through vivino
they have a bunch of peer reviews they
also have descriptors where the wine is
from
and these people who are here online
reviewing these wines they're wine
fanatics
they can tell you in the language that
you need to help you understand what
you're tasting
and by the way not just for purchasing
wine you can use the app
to scan a bottle of wine like when
you're in the grocery store
just to see what other people think
about the wine you're about to buy it's
freaking awesome you could use this app
for
anybody from a novice wine user to
somebody who's an expert
so i've really stepped up my wine game
thanks to vivino give them a try and i
know you're going to love it go to
vivino.com
brain and use codebrain at checkout to
save 20
on your first order up to 200 that's v
i v i n o dot com slash brain
code brain to save twenty percent on
your first order
of up to two hundred dollars the vino
dot com slash brain code brain
see site for details terms apply it's
correct
go ahead my k-town stories have to do
with karaoke rooms oh yeah and i didn't
know how
crazy karaoke wasn't like i went my
asian homegirl took me to this one spot
it blew my mind i thought i was in the
movie that's only seen that in like
asian
movies like every room was huge it was
just like
and just everyone was in there dancing
and singing i was the only black person
in there
well all right let's do it
they come through you get bottle service
it was crazy but the funny thing we've
been trying to figure out for the past
years the only women that holler at me
are asian women
and we've been trying to figure out what
is it about me that they like and
everyone say i got big eyes
i'm like that's so stereotypical to go
to that first but i'm like
i don't know what it is but they the
ones that holler at me into your soul
yeah they really like him they really
like him and we still don't have the
answer to it yeah
first girl i met out here asian doesn't
have a bunch of asians
asian girls not like this is my
girlfriend but yeah just
having fun what was that experience like
for you different it was cool
i like people with culture that's why i
don't think i can date like a white girl
because i need culture yeah like at the
end of the day
no no but when we say yeah they didn't
have sex too differently
two different things i'm talking about
this
all about you know multiplying
generations but i just need culture so
if i can date outside my race but it'll
be asian it could be indians
some people that just have culture
that's what i mean what is that though
because i feel the same way because i've
definitely
dated a couple of white girls and it
just something didn't click
i think it's just because they didn't
get their ass beat when they're younger
or something i feel like there's like
this certain struggle that you need to
go through
i feel like there there are few out
there that may understand whether they
were
raised around a certain group of people
or so like but it's like
when i'm thinking when i'm talking about
white girl working i'm talking about
like you know
laguna beach like from the source the so
you know from the south i can't do this
i can't do this i can't see the
kardashians
super attractive sound like a door going
into it
so that yeah so it's just like you just
got to have some type of
culture balance like because i feel like
it gets to a point when it's like those
especially like if you look at
everything that happened last year you
know with george floyd and everything
it's like when it when those moments
happen it's like
are you having my back because you just
feel like you know
or do you really feel so you know what
i'm saying it's a you went deep with it
i'm shallow with
you ain't never seen snowfall you ain't
never seen boys in the hood like
we got to have a balance i want to go
tap into what you into
but we need a balance like there's
certain things you just don't know i
mean
it's hard because you know what it is
too it's also a sense of humor that's
that's the biggest biggest [ __ ]
difference it's like [ __ ] that makes you
laugh doesn't make them laugh
yeah like even with my fiance because
she didn't grow up around any black
people
yeah people watch certain movies films
or whatever and then i'm cracking up and
she goes i don't get it
yeah [ __ ] i might have to leave you like
like what you mean
i didn't know you didn't get this before
we were watching like
i mean there's like like marlin right
the second season i don't like the first
season of my second season it's just
marlin just roasting
yeah this room so i'm cracking up my
marlin's [ __ ] ridiculous she goes i
don't get why this is funny i'm like you
just [ __ ] what does she find funny
though like what's something that
like [ __ ] puppy videos and [ __ ] i
should like you see this i'm like
[ __ ] you like don't show me this [ __ ] i
know the ending this
puppy's gonna fart like i know what's
gonna happen don't tell me the [ __ ] is
there a show she like that
you're not into oh there's a [ __ ]
there's so much
you know what i mean but what i like
about her though is that she's very
inquisitive and she's not afraid to ask
questions so when the black lives matter
thing happened right she didn't
understand why i was so upset
yeah she didn't get it she just was like
oh this is a tragedy she said why are
you upset
i was like i don't know i even know how
to explain it yeah because
it's not something that you really grew
up with you didn't see a lot of people
look here and say
i'm half
my credit scores
but she she was always like she never
understood like
the funniest things that she would ask
and it's not it's funny to me because
she was like
how come black women wear silk stuff on
their head before they go to sleep
i'm like oh this is a question that most
people wouldn't no
yeah that wasn't real but the only
reason why i know i grew up in a black
beauty supply store so yeah this is why
i know
so she she would just always ask these
things which is really smart
people don't they would either pretend
like they know or they would just judge
from a distance yeah so
i think that's what i really like about
it yeah we're so afraid to ask questions
like i
i ask questions like i remember one of
my homies he's
white and i asked him i said hey bro
i'll be honest with you
do white people iron like
you be wrinkled a lot bro like
he was like a lot of that i've never
touched the iron i was like see i know
i'm like these are questions i just need
to know i'm like
i remember first time i spent the night
at my friend mike's house he was white i
was in uh middle school
i said uh i'm about to take shout outs
can i get a washcloth he said what's
that
what's that what's that like what you
use the washi like we just use a soap
bar
so i went in there looked at the soap i
was like all right
i saw some body washes i'm using the
body wash and i took like you know those
medium towels that you use
the white dry things i took one of them
that was my washcloth hotel tell me
about this washcloth is yeah that's
different cultures
there's like like hygiene [ __ ] is way
different well you know for asian people
like the shoes in the house
is the biggest thing that's great like
i didn't know i had to explain it to
anybody but it was like a very american
thing not to
you just bring your shoes in and then
like i remember i explained to one of my
friends like well why do you do
that i was like you i literally saw you
stepping [ __ ] before you came in here
you walked
in the grass and you stopped the [ __ ]
that's why we do it like
it's it's annoying like we don't it's
hard to clean that [ __ ] yeah
oh he went back and his parents started
taking off their shoes because
because he got [ __ ] in his head he was
like oh my god like yeah
i can't believe so his parents just
stopped wearing shoes in the house after
that
but there's like very huge cultures like
my grandma oh you she used to
be like don't wear your outside pants on
the bed yeah and i used to always forget
and i would go to sit on the bench
oh yeah that's right and i would change
because they don't want the [ __ ] on the
bed but it made sense i'm like
oh yeah i have been out all day i've
been sitting on benches and i've been
i mean i get it you know i didn't even
think about that [ __ ] until my fiance
yeah like because i when we first
started dating yeah i was in a room
and i sat my outside pants on her bed
and she was like get up oh god i was
like why she goes outside clothes
i was like you want me to get naked
outside
you have outside clothes you don't put
it on the bed that's where i sleep
yeah and it just blew my mind i'm like
damn that's smart
you're like oh [ __ ] i've been dirty for
a little while yeah i've been [ __ ]
sleeping in my own filthy [ __ ]
yeah she didn't tell nobody told me this
i watched a study where they like
took certain people's bed sheets bro and
just like
ran all type of like science tests on
them and just
the dirt that your body just accumulates
throughout throughout the day
is crazy not even you being dirty but
just like walking outside just the air
outside it's like oh [ __ ] like we bring
all that [ __ ] so they were talking about
how often you should wash your bed seats
they said some people don't watch their
bed sheets for like a year bro nah
that's the
you can smell it but you can smell that
[ __ ] wash your veggies in here i'm
like
you can smell it that don't make sense
and men just stink in general
so like i got a solid like two and a
half days and i'm like this is done
like what's the longest you've been
without taking a shower me oh i
i i can't i take a sh i take two showers
a day every day no no
longer as i did as long as you did it's
only when i went camping
okay so camping was like three four days
a day yeah what got you to do starting
doing that my mom beat
my ass gotcha that's what it was trauma
trauma promise
problem we're starting to learn the
pattern with you you it was a lot of
problems
everything was through a fist so if i
every morning i would take a shower
before i go to school
and uh at night i would have to take a
shower before i go to sleep okay
and there's a few things i didn't know
until i was an adult like you don't have
to shampoo
all the [ __ ] time yeah so like four
years ago i was like losing my hair
and i was like yo how am i [ __ ]
balding already what the [ __ ] is going
on
and i just did one google search and it
was like most people over shampoo
and i'm like me over shampoo i was
shampooing twice a day oh yeah i was
just ripping my hair out
and then i just stopped doing that and
then my hair grew back so i was doing
that for
all the way till i was like what 20
[ __ ] yeah 28 or some [ __ ]
it's funny how some trauma can make you
better and some trauma could just make
it
worse yeah i grew up with um
like i'm so positive because i heard a
lot of pessimism and
you know around me sometimes so i was
like i just got tired of hearing like
why think worse first
and like i was like i need to break that
chain so that's why i'm so positive
today so that trauma
and just figuring out like you're more
hygienic because you got beat if you
didn't
yeah yeah sometimes it works yeah even
like crazy like my mom just do the same
thing take the show in the morning get
home to take a shower at night and then
i got so rebellious when i got older i
was like
i'm on my own now i'm just gonna take it
in the morning because ain't nobody
gonna tell me what the [ __ ]
but then you think about you like maybe
i should take one of that maybe i have
been more important tonight in the
morning
but you know what the other factor was
for me though i couldn't be the [ __ ]
fat guy that stunk
like i thought i'd be a good smelly fat
guy at least yeah yeah because one of
the things
all the home girl says you always smell
good it's because i can't be the fat guy
that smells nice yeah you want cologne
recommendations i go to fast yeah
one time this dude huge dude walked by
me in the club
bro i almost gave him my number i said
i tapped him i said man
i don't know how to tell you this bro
but you smell [ __ ]
good dog he said oh i appreciate that
man that's what you know i do
i do it for compliments like it's all i
got is
if you don't know i'm really insecure in
other areas but
and i was like so then i was like let me
try but i know he's not going i was like
so what like what what what is that i
can't tell you nah nah man i can you
know i can't do that i was like all
right that's fair
that's my sense if you're a stranger i
can tell you if you in my circle
i can't you can't smell the same in your
circle i don't know you
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely a fat
person thing is what i found out because
i have my own clone mix like that i
mix up myself and everybody's like oh
you smell really good yeah don't ask me
for the recipe i'll kill you
i'm a chemist in there yeah we can't
walk around smelling the same like it
doesn't work that way
because that's that's the one thing that
my fiancee loved about she goes you
always used to smell good well
once once we got
yeah but like i remember when i was
biggest dude like smelling smelling good
was very important
and then on top of that too it's just
like you always had a talent that's why
i used to sing and play the guitar
actually because it was hard to talk to
women like because everybody else was
either the jock they were super fit or
whatever i was i was broke and fat i was
like this is
i gotta figure out something handicapped
like i gotta do something i gotta smell
nice i have to like walk by them and
like what are you smelling like what's
funny i wear women's deodorant
oh you don't even wear more deodorant
they say women sweat more so i like i
use that i use uh
um what is it degree uh sheer powder
mm-hmm it smells like cotton
secrets right here shower clean yes yeah
i switch between those two i don't know
when it's time like
after a while don't last i'm not alright
you know i don't get b.o you don't get
b.o i don't get b.o i'm not a b.o person
i don't get it i'm like the very small
percentage that doesn't get bo that's
cool
i think the one time i might have had
like some semblance of it is i was
playing ball for like [ __ ] like 10
hours
and then i had it but it's very hard for
me to get it so i didn't know what bo
was for the longest
time i was like well my cousin has the
worst bo ever i was like bro do you just
swim in trash
like what the [ __ ] is this you just swim
dog you smell like [ __ ]
like like an actual [ __ ] anus like
that's what you smell like
not showering so funnier story hey if
you watch this podcast i don't give a
[ __ ]
these are facts this dude we were
so we should spend spend the night in
each other's house right i remember i
accidentally walked him
walked in on him in the shower and i got
to witness for the first time how he
showers
this [ __ ] just hits the water
arms down to his side and just lets it
hit his face
that's how he would shower no soap no
laughs no soap no nothing
i was like that's why you [ __ ] smell
so we just roasted his ass for like a
whole year
it's funny i just seen something online
we talked about on our podcast but it
was accident it was
three white people and they asked the
girl they was like uh how do you how
often do you shower she like
oh maybe once every two weeks first of
all i thought like
down there must be oh yeah or anything
and then they're like how do you shout
out she's like i just wash my hair and
let that run down my body
no i said so you're not getting in the
crevices
you're not like that's not clean and
they didn't react
the guys didn't react like that i was
like nah there's no way she can smell
good no way that you're clean
she's not coming to my house that's
[ __ ] dingleberry forest yeah oh yeah
it is
it is it got to be bad down there it is
it's got to be bad
dude high school there was a dude i'm
not going to i almost said his name
but this guy he was trying to make fun
of one of our other friends because he
was saying he washed his ass and you
know like when you're younger
everything's homophobic yeah yeah
and he was like oh you [ __ ] touch
your ass you gay say no he goes
wait hold on a second everybody paused
and we looked at him but the group were
like
you don't wash your ass he's like nah
i'm not gay i'm like hold on a second
bro
this podcast is brought to you by man
escaped my friends have you been
trimming your ball sack
with the same old face razor your whole
life well that just
means my friends that you have pubes in
your mouth and i've guaranteed you've
nicked your balls
multiple times well no more having a
hairy nut sack in a hairy private place
you need
manscape it's sleek it's amazing did i
mention that their lawnmower 4.0 has
wireless charging
what in the technology are we talking
about right now
and by the way ladies out there if your
man doesn't like
shaving that's because he doesn't have
manscape you should get him
a pair of manscape lawnmower 4.0s
have you noticed that your man also has
nose hairs well guess what have you
heard of the weed whacker i actually use
this all the time
those nose hairs audio sucker so to all
my
genius brain listeners get 20 off and
free shipping with code geniusbrain
at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code geniusbrain
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools
for the job with manscaped you got
dingleberries bro
he's like what the [ __ ] you mean he goes
bro wash your [ __ ] ass
yeah we call them dingleberries
throughout all of high school and this
was so upset
till this day like randomly the other
day i was on facebook i didn't go on
facebook for years
four years ago the same dude that wrote
them about the dingleberries just
randomly wrote on my facebook hey
remember that one time we called that
full diggleberry
and it was the anniversary of it he
didn't wash his ass because he thought
that [ __ ] was gay yeah that that's the
thing that goes around
if you you do you wash your [ __ ] you
if you do you you gay
i'm like wait what take the rag today oh
yeah get in there get in there
get in that thing i didn't know that
[ __ ] white people don't use
washcloths
i didn't know ethan until i went over
here listen white viewers please
comment under here and let us know if
was that an old thing is it
it's like we do now yeah it's like you
know so let me tell you about the
whitest thing i've seen
uh this is what two days ago we're at
our friend's house
it's his birthday funny i loved him but
his wife
starts talking she's like we have a cat
i don't like cats
and she was like he has his own room he
was like everyone's like [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] she's like no he has his
own room we're like what's up we're
asking her questions and she was like
well how about we just go see the room
let's just go so it's like five of us in
the line walking we go into the main
house
we see the cat that cat's big as [ __ ]
i'm talking i'm not going over it i'm
talking about i don't trust him it's
look like
i don't trust him i don't trust him
[ __ ] got a [ __ ] black in my
opinion
like a big ass cat so he sees us coming
in he gets anxiety he runs off she's
like oh he's going to his room so now we
walk to the room
he has a fool like this like this with a
bunch of things in there
beds and things to climb on and then it
leads to their room the next room i was
like
this is the widest yeah i turn around to
the people
this is the whitest thing i've ever seen
and then we're just saying this to you
like his normal [ __ ] yeah she's like
why why shouldn't he have a room we said
cause he's a [ __ ] cause i didn't have
a room till i was 14.
why couldn't you talk about that because
a white person
i want to be reborn as a white person if
i was a pet i would want to be owned by
a white person
they take you everywhere they take you
they feed you
gourmet meals it's just ridic like he
had a whole room bro closing everything
he got little cat suits in there
it's it's it was crazy mine is [ __ ]
blowing yeah no
it threw us off i was like she's playing
no way he has a whole room my man has a
whole room
what the [ __ ] there has to be some white
people like no that's not white people
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy i think it's
white people like i didn't i
so because of where i grew up i didn't
grow up around like white culture
like sacramento does have a lot of white
people it's just where i was at in
sacramento you didn't have a lot of
white people
but when i went to college is when i
first was around the most
whiteness of my life college uh i went
to ucr
and ucr doesn't actually has like the
most like cultural diversity at
all universities because it was the only
university that was that breakdown ucr
oh university of california riverside
okay
at the time it was so easy to get in
like you didn't have to apply they're
like you're in
so like
i legit got in and i didn't know i
applied and they're like it's like
you've made it and i'm like that's how
shitty your [ __ ] college is yeah
because i had a 2.6 or 7 gpa it was
super [ __ ] low
like i was dumb as rocks and so they let
me in there
and it was the hardest part for me was
like we were talking about earlier was
the sense of humor thing i just didn't
get any other jokes yeah i'm like
i don't know what it is like i don't
know how to describe what like white
american humor is right yeah
it's like i don't know it's like
hypothetical situations or some [ __ ] or
or something and i would just be the
only person not laughing i'm like i
don't get this
yeah yeah i just never understood it and
until i in my dorm room
of out of all the people i like
connected to [ __ ] three black women
i just kicked it with them all right we
love david
they don't talk everybody they were cool
i sat them on the [ __ ]
stoop i started bringing their hair [ __ ]
out of my life
david and their partner like yeah girls
so tell me what's going on hey what you
for to get it dude
all right roommate come hey get the [ __ ]
out of there this ain't for you
after college i got a job at this place
and it was all white
oh this is all white and then i started
just picking up on their humor
and a lot of humor is references like
they're like yeah dave malarkey
and this and that and i'm like who the
[ __ ] is dave they know all the celebrity
names they know all the gossip
and that and working there for two years
i started
catching up on names i'm like oh yeah
yeah dave
it was it was a fun experience to learn
and like see it from a different
perspective because i didn't have any
issues with them
it was a lot of old people in there but
it was just a cool experience to see how
their mind works and what they talk
about
yeah because when i started watching
like a lot more like different standards
outside of the normal people that i
normally watch like i watched
people that i just didn't find funny i
had to look at it i'm like why is this
funny like it's funny
there's gotta be something there because
there's millions of people watching this
[ __ ] that get this
yeah i just don't right so it's like
this person is funny
why don't i get it though you know i
just never grew up like bo burnham
oh yeah he's kind he's wild yeah so bo
burnham started doing stand up and i was
like
i don't find this funny but there's
millions of people oh yeah so there's
something funny about this [ __ ] yeah
and so i i didn't understand that i
started watching uh what's it uh dane
cook
like dane cook was doing stand-up comedy
i was like this is not that funny to me
either
but he sold out magic square garden so
there's something i'm missing here
there's a piece that's missing
i think it's just about sometimes it
takes time like i remember
my ex she all she want to watch is
seinfeld
and that's when i was i was young
was in there i don't get this i got
older yeah
and it's it was like yo this is funny
but then i started watching curb i was
like
larry davis a comedic genius like i
started getting it more sometimes
it's a time machine it's like it's like
old stuff you were like oh
they're talking about adult that's why i
didn't understand because
i think like growing up like 90 sitcoms
was very performative right
so it's a lot of big movements even like
def jam comedy yeah
all the def jam comics at the time super
performance yeah
big movements jumping humping [ __ ]
falling on the floor kicking [ __ ]
exactly so that's what our expectation
of what comedy was it wasn't even so
much what they were saying it was what
they were doing yeah when you get a
seinfeld he's sitting at a diner talking
and he's like
what what is this [ __ ] who's he talking
about one of my favorite
comedic actors of all time passed away
jerry stiller mm-hmm
yeah hilarious he wasn't he was the
funniest person
hilarious and then he went on king of
queens and he just played the same
[ __ ] character on
all his movies he was funny yeah he was
so [ __ ] hilarious and i didn't even
know that was ben stiller's dad
and like i've one of one of this one of
the comedians that i'm finding funny
white guy
i think i showed them a couple of times
but his name is nate bargotz
bargatsi or something like that but the
way he tells
his jokes is like it's kind of like how
i like my joke i like kind of like that
deadpan sarcastic
humor sometimes and he like for example
he's telling this one joke about how
he has this six-year-old daughter and or
she might be six or seven
this is his first time heard going to
the bus stop uh to take the bus
so he said you know me and my wife i've
been married to my wife 14 years
it was like um so we walk her down to
the bus
she gets on the bus she goes to school
he said mind you the school has
my number and they have my wife's number
cool mom dad he's like just so y'all
understand
he said later on that day i get a phone
call on my cell phone
from school so i pick up me he's like
i'm like hello and they're like hey mr
bargotsky he's like uh yeah what's going
on
hey we're just calling to just uh ask
would you happen to know your daughter's
uh
bus number he goes
he says so you have my wife's number and
my number and you chose to call me
[Laughter]
and he's like have you ever grown up
with a father before
that [ __ ] was so funny because it was so
related i was like that's a man [ __ ]
he was like well matter of fact why
don't you ask me where the school is at
for all i care i don't know what that is
he was like but as getting old i'm like
oh i get that because
men we don't we don't be that's why that
joke was so funny
because that [ __ ] was too factual this
is funny it happens
all the [ __ ] time without fail the
closer it is the facts you're like
yeah no that's what i hate about my
parents they'll call me and say how to
do this on their phone
i told you i don't know how to use an
android i got an [ __ ]
when you switched when you said i'm
getting an android i said don't do it
yeah i don't know if you don't call me
ask me things i have no idea about
like y'all gotta have the same phone as
me if you wanna be calling me asking me
for advice on your phone when you
thousands of miles away if at least if
i'm there i can figure it out yeah yeah
but
you can't even hold the phone right i
could use he gotta get my mom phone to
record his phone
and he'd be having it here i like you
got to hold up the phone so i could see
oh bro he's old hands
let me tell you this dude i'm not even
lying about this this is this is when i
knew
like how old my [ __ ] uncle was so
they
we got them a computer right this was
never had a computer before he doesn't
understand the concept of a computer
bro he didn't understand what this is he
goes what do you mean you could take
things and put it into a folder
that's a tv like
and i'm getting frustrated i'm getting
pissed right because of how stupid he is
yeah and i'm like hey you can't talk to
me like this
and have you respect you after this
conversation i don't respect you anymore
i'm not even [ __ ] lying my cousins
were there
i cannot make the [ __ ] up let's say this
this is the mouse of the computer
right i go well first of all you have to
turn on the computer he goes how do i
turn it on i was like how do you think
you turn it on
this is the mouse he goes hello
bro no he takes the mouse and he starts
talking to the mouse
like it was a [ __ ] intercom hello
and i was like excuse me how old is he
huh at this time he was like 65
no nonsense
hey i don't give a [ __ ] i've never had
somebody grab a mouse and go hello
like i was like yo i will [ __ ] you up
right now bro you were [ __ ] around
with me
he starts getting mad at me because i'm
explaining to him the concept
of folders right yeah so this is how i
have to teach
old ass asian people how to use a
computer i have to write them a diagram
on on note paper and i was like hey so
what you're going to do number one you
go to this thing that looks like this i
have to draw the folder
you're going to double click have you
ever tried to teach an old person how to
double click on that that sounds crazy
bro six hours of my life i'll never get
back because that's because you can't
even explain double click
yeah it's like faster he goes no
no no click click
bro i'm just kidding just you know when
you get [ __ ]
in it for like even when we 50 we gonna
be filming doings like it's gonna be so
i feel like we gonna be on it but like
and that's why he needs a show man he
got so many good stories like you could
have a show like
dave call it so i wanna watch that
because this is so much funny
it's hard like i'm trying to get these
networks to understand because the thing
about like
asian family life they only see it in
one way
it's like parents they're like oh these
stories are crazy i was like these
stories are real
like i'm talking about that same uncle i
witnessed that man throw a cleaver at my
at my cousin once because he got so mad
at him i'm talking about a
butcher cleveland went into the wall
next to his head
and then they just had dinner like it
was nothing are you hungry it's like bro
you almost killed me
yeah what are you talk like our our
family life was so [ __ ] weird because
my my uncle too
he i had weird stories because he they
worked at a flea market
and so oh let me i don't know if i've
told this story too
well this [ __ ] is [ __ ] nuts i wanted
to put this in the movie but i'll just
tell now it doesn't matter
so my uncle used to work at a flea
market with my aunt right
so in the morning we have to wake up at
5 00 or 4 a.m to go help them
i hated this oh yeah of course because
they would use all the kids in the
family they're like hey we need help so
i had to wake up at 4 a.m
set up the [ __ ] tens and if i didn't
wake up in time i get my ass beat but
i'd be so tired i don't even know where
the fists are coming to [ __ ]
and so i would go to this [ __ ] store
and in the morning
our our neighbors were muslim right they
would pray in the morning
this is these are just facts right don't
judge me i didn't do this
so he's muslim in the morning and he
would pray that's how dedicated muslim
people are to the religion is
something very beautiful so my uncle
doesn't understand the severity of when
you shouldn't make fun of people's
religions yeah right because he thinks
that it's all fun and games yeah
he's a jackass so this guy and his name
is his american name is charlie by the
way
the guy's praying you know it's it's
loud he's doing his prayers
my uncle in the middle of his prayer at
5 a.m when the sun's about to come
starts to go
shut up he said too loud to the dude
that's praying
yeah so the guy walks over to him and
goes charlie we're friends
if you ever disrespect me like that in
my religion i'll have to kill you
and by charlie i'm gonna repeat this
right
yeah like i said i didn't say this
and you have to understand that asian
immigrants only learn stuff from people
around them
yeah he looks at him he goes he goes man
shut up you're just a sad [ __ ]
like that i went i'm eight years old or
something i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that i've never heard
this phrase before
i was like i was like bro you can't say
that to him he goes that's
what everybody else said he's like he
said my [ __ ] that's
my [ __ ] i'm like what is going on
you know what it was it's because the
black dude's next to him would have
teached him this [ __ ] yeah yeah
how did the guy react huh he just went
you're [ __ ] dumb
yeah she's walking because i'm like i
think he treated him like he was a
village idiot he's like this guy's
[ __ ] crazy
right because he was a little nuts but
it's because the people next were
teaching him [ __ ] yeah but they but
that's like this is inside [ __ ]
to and like i just remember sitting
there just mortified like yo i'm gonna
get killed today yeah i'm gonna
today's the day yeah yeah today uncle
yeah that's crazy that's hilarious
that's wild a lot of asian a lot of like
these old asian dudes they learn stuff
from people around them but they don't
know like the cultural consequences of
it
because it's all inside that's why you
got to make friends everywhere else so
they can be like hey bro
or that's why the younger people in the
family gotta let them know hey
i had i had a church leader this fool's
name was
tiger because when he first came to the
states people in
the office that he was working at
they're like oh i need a new american
name
somebody give me the name somebody was
like bro call yourself tiger as a white
person joke
he goes to the dmv that he chases dave
the tiger he goes back he goes my name
is tiger they're like bro
we were kidding yeah yeah calm down his
name is tiger lee
that's tiger until this day till this
day his name is tiger lee
you can't do nothing but embrace it
that's all that it is
the immigrant asian experience is so
weird but also my parents were really
[ __ ] weird too
like my mom i started realizing when i
was hanging out
around other people's parents my
family's just weird in general
like it's like because i would tell
these asian stories like that's not
asian bro
like uh but for example like my mom the
way that she speaks to me is from this
area in korea called it's like challenge
is like country bumpkinship like they
only use slang all the time
so the way that my mom speaks to me is
how like korean gangsters talk
so that's funny see this this is why
it's so funny to me like watching that
and hear his mom talk like a gangster
would be the funniest
this is not even a joke my mom used to
call me a [ __ ] growing up all the time
in korean
i thought that that was like a nickname
because i didn't know what the
what the consequences were until i went
to college and i started watching korean
like gang films
and it translated and he said [ __ ] i
was like yo what the [ __ ]
i was like have you been calling me a
[ __ ] my whole life and she was so you
didn't understand i didn't know
so she was so it's like i just knew it
was like an insult
right but for some reason i never pieced
the word is kezeki k means dog seki
means
child so you're a [ __ ] so my mom would
be like you little [ __ ]
and i just called me a [ __ ] all day
yeah i'm listening to this wrong i'm
like damn he has the same name i do like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
my mom used to roast my ass
but it's crazy that you're in it and
still didn't know oh i didn't know
that's that's the wild part like when
she
when she dumped when i got dumped for
the first time in my life this is how
[ __ ] gangster this woman is
i was bawling in my room crying like
every young man should be i'm crying
my mom comes into my room like straight
up like old school sitcom style opens
the door she goes why are you crying son
in korean
right i'm like i just got dumb i got my
heart broken don't tell dad like he's
going to make fun of me he's going to
try to come and talk to me i want to
talk to him she goes
she puts her hand on my shoulder she
literally says in korean
only little girls cry in a room by
themselves stop being a [ __ ]
she just walks out and close the door i
start bawling even more and then i hear
my mom she goes
david's crying because he just got
dumped out
and he's like over here trying to talk
to me about like his like he's like
women they come in a dime a dozen don't
worry about it she's not worth your time
like i don't want to hear you [ __ ] but
that's why you're not sensitive now well
at least i don't think you are because
i'm stabbed yeah i gotta go through it
yeah like my family like that's jokes
like you gotta be able to
a lot of people don't so when i first
came to la i didn't realize that a lot
of people
are sensitive like that right because i
only i'm in a small group i didn't [ __ ]
with a lot of people
so how i interact with my personal
friends is how i think everybody else is
going to yeah you roast them all day
and so like this one girl uh i mean
we're good friends now she didn't talk
to me for like a year i didn't know she
would send me until her husband told me
because we were at a party and you know
we're drunk she makes a fat joke at me
i'm like oh she wants to go and this
girl [ __ ] flat chest
you're getting excited yeah i [ __ ]
roasted the [ __ ] out of her because
she's like sensitive about her flat
chest i was like
got it i already know and she had a nose
like owen wilson so i was just
roasting her ass bro and i was like dude
i bet you could just [ __ ] lay on your
back and collect water on the concave
titties i was just going in on her bro
so i just told her the villa the village
well and so she just
that sounded a good joke in front of her
husband in front of her and he lied
and then she didn't talk to me for like
two years and i didn't know why you're
like what happened uh
i thought we were going because in your
mind you're like oh i'll see you next
week
we're trying to get hold on today you
didn't find out until two years later
and so i'd explained to him i was like
but she
initiated it she made the fat joke i was
like oh well let's
[ __ ] go yeah and so i thought she was
about that life and ever since then i
just never made fun of her
so now i just let people make fun of me
and i don't say anything back because
i don't know because how i take it
versus how they take it is going to be
different
so it's like they don't know how to
laugh at themselves they put they put me
and
david up against each other on that mtv
show this man david hit me
with a haymaker cause i had like a
button up on it was buttoned up and i
had shorts on
he was like they was like i didn't know
i was going to meet a jamaican youth
pastor
i was in there i was like god
actually was funny but i love that's how
we show love and it's like that's just
what we do as comedians like we just
we always just go we're not gonna come
up and say hey that's a nice shirt oh
yeah first thing i said i gotta go look
at this [ __ ] daddy
but that's really just telling you hey
dude you're doing a good job you're
doing great in life
yeah this factual is fun i chose not to
have sweet tea in case i can't make fun
of i'm like
i'm just going to sit on the porch and
pretend like i'm not going to do it i
wouldn't love you all as neighbors if i
was
your mother hey take your fat ass inside
the board hey we go for a walk let's go
yeah you don't want to be like
everything's so serious
it's just too hard to live that way yeah
it's way too much if you can't make fun
of your friends then what the [ __ ]
it's like also too was like when you
when they make funny you're supposed to
laugh
too yeah yeah it's not you just being
made fun of you have to clap back or
even if you don't just laugh at it man
you're like oh you you like mike
he's the skinniest one in the groove
we've like shut your fat ass up
he's never been fat but we just
different compared to all you guys
when i see like his photos and [ __ ] i'm
like oh you different yeah
but he's always been he's got yeah i've
known him since sixth grade so
nothing shocks me what he did head
tattoo that's mike he's
always he's a libra and he's he's the
only child so
he's always been changing he's always
trying to do something new
always when i saw that fool put up a
picture of himself in a mesh t-shirt i
was like bro you look like a sweet bag
of onions
like how the [ __ ] is
nothing shocks me if i'm ever shocked by
something he does
like okay something something right
something's there like i'm shocked like
nothing can shock i'm like the only
person i know that can rock that it
looks normal
the funniest thing to us right now he's
doing the 70s style so he has these like
boots and they click
the first day the first day he wore them
we thought it was a woman was in the
house
i'm sitting there typing out here and
i'm like
is there a girl in the hallway so and
then we look and the sliding door is
closed where the podcast is he's in the
living room he's walking by
me and rolling laughing he looks at us
he don't know we're laughing at him
we are dying then like two days later
i'm in my room room's in his room
we here to click again but outside i
just started laughing i'm thinking i'm
the only one to hear it i hear him start
laughing we bust out laughs
so far
he's always been like that he's all
upset
it's just great to make fun of each
other it's fun man
that's how you show love his music is
getting like substantially better yeah
now it's good
and that's another thing with mike mike
well always he's the most talented
person i know
like and he'll always try something new
and he's always gonna be trash at first
yeah but he's gonna keep going and get
better like djing at first
trash now he's the best dj i know this
music when he first started trash but
now he's getting way better he's making
pizza way
better so i was like there's nothing i
don't think he can't do now he's
learning guitar so i'm like right now
he's trash and we but i know at some
point he's going to get better we also
don't know
how long it's going to last so we just
we roll with it yeah we will be like all
right
in three more years he might decide to
go be a monk or a painter and we'll be
like
you know what the worst part is though
you guys have to be a part of the
inception so
when somebody just starts learning
guitar [ __ ] all off key you're not
knowing [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] hearing this singing all
day long all right man i'm trying to
sleep
and he got different hours you know yeah
i'm early scary hours
you don't know artist people have weird
hours dude yeah like when they get
energy is when they work
yeah so it's like you never know what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen are you still
uh
you still practice or interest oh i
can't play guitar at all anymore man
yeah it's hard like
i lost all the callous in my fingers and
i haven't really been saying
i'm trying to get back on keys but then
like even just getting back to basics
again you be like [ __ ] man i'm i'm rusty
i'm rusty as [ __ ] but but it's just one
of those things you just got it's a
that's a daily thing you gotta
keep going with it i feel like every
black person i know knows how to play
the drums a little bit just
just tap it just that's just a rhythm
i'm sorry to disappoint you man
but he's saying even if you
me and you were talking last night i was
like i definitely want to talk about
travel because
yeah yeah yeah uh how many
when's the last time you went out the
country uh
two years ago i was in japan japan and
then before that
uh taiwan okay yeah okay because yeah me
and him
we've been first off we've been feigning
the goal
because so our so maybe you can help us
well
we kind of already know but our choices
were we're trying to figure out where do
we want to go so we had brazil up there
we had
and then where kovid wants us to go yeah
so then we had brazil so we had brazil
we had uh
uh dr possibly we had um
costa rica and then first we had just
santorini greece we was like but that's
too romantic
so then our homeboy was like but you
ever thought about mykonos and i was
like she said i think party stuff
yeah that's what everybody says and i
was like oh and so we started
researching that and we were like all
right so it was between kind of costa
rica
and that my nose is a tad bit it's a tad
bit expensive
but um costa rica we was like it's kind
of right there we could
always go to because it's like four and
a half hour flight so we're thinking
like if we're gonna go out the country
like
go out the country like you know so
that's what that's what we're aiming for
now to go because like travel is just
because my knowledge is supposed to be
the party area and it's supposed to be
cheaper than greece
yeah well it isn't it is green but it's
going to be like
exactly so like if you're if you go to
mykonos it's like cheaper than
everywhere else it's not like the
the hot toys like athens exactly so it's
like
people go out there to parties like a
younger crowd yeah this is what i heard
from a couple of friends
like traveling it's it's when when
pandemic hits so i was actually supposed
to go to vietnam for a month
and we were going to do the whole thing
like village side like stay with like
people people type of stuff i uh booked
business class tickets to there because
your boy you were a little bigger
yeah tinier same with us
we're not doing a conversation i can't
do it that way he'll die
it's too much yeah and plus you want to
be well rested when you get there so you
could actually do your [ __ ]
so i when i when i first got there it
was like when i first got business class
i just remember i was like
i can't go back like this is this is too
nice
dude let me tell you something too like
i
because i'm not used to this type of
treatment i'm trying to stay awake the
whole flight
because because i don't want to miss
nothing for this
you're looking around around they bring
you something oh more if there's more
like like sir you can get food whenever
you want i'm like
whenever i was like give me 17
bottles of water right now give it to me
now it's like oh we'll give you as much
drinks as you want yeah and but when
you're elevated too like you get drunk
way faster so yeah
i was all upset i'm like [ __ ] three
glasses of wine i'm done oh yeah
yeah it's nice though like traveling is
like one of those things i feel like
everybody should do you got to
and uh and not just like i'm talking
about like go somewhere where you just
wouldn't think you ever gonna be it like
it's scary for people
no it's scary for me every time it is
i'm scared every [ __ ] time i don't
know the language i don't know you don't
know what's gonna happen
but the thing about it is it's like i
think we're we always look for comfort
right but discomfort is also important
for growth so when you're in an area too
it also helps me kind of put myself into
perspective what my parents went through
when they first came to this country
they couldn't speak the language at all
that's crazy blows my [ __ ] mind yeah
i made a living off this [ __ ] i could
never do that i already know i'm staying
where i'm at
this is i'm not going to [ __ ] mika
knows literally that [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude
falafel every day i don't know what
their life is like
but like when i when i first started
traveling because i have [ __ ] crazy
anxiety
but i always deal with it by putting
myself in uncomfortable situations even
if it if it makes me feel bad i have to
do it because there's like a weakness
that i see in myself that i just
want it gone i don't want it there it
bothers me
like even when i first started doing
something like kickboxing right
in my mind bro i thought i was nice i
was like i was like telling myself like
yo bro you you good
to see it every day on ig and then i saw
my first
video i was like yo somebody slowed my
video down bro this dude slow as [ __ ]
but that was a good perspective yeah and
every day when i went there i felt like
i was going to throw up
yeah the first month i tore my rotator
cuff i went back i just started using
the jab instead yeah
and then i tore my meniscus and i just
kept going and going and going i was
like yo
i think i was i think i would have
stopped because surgery and rehab
ain't funny yeah it's gonna be fun dude
i mean recently i've been able to bend
my knee back just because of rehab
but there's like that's what travel does
to me too it makes me uncomfortable and
it helps me like to see how other people
live their life
because we as americans we're so good at
telling people how they should live
their lives oh yeah because we think
that what we do is right all the [ __ ]
time
and the other people in other countries
i realize they look at us like who the
[ __ ] you think yeah
you know entitled city over here exactly
so when i see how other people behave
and how they act i'm like
you know the world is so [ __ ] big
it's just some beautiful places gotta
see it
it's something beautiful whatever i got
to see it all
i haven't just that's why i don't have a
lot of time to travel as much as i used
to but the mo
i always go to hawaii because it's a
state but it's not really a state
it's island you know it's like it's a
state whatever
you know hawaii is its own culture it's
something completely different
and that's the place too where there's
not a lot of white people
and it's a state it's a weird thing yeah
right so like when a lot of these asian
attacks were happening out in hawaii
they're like we don't know what the [ __ ]
that's like
everybody's asian out here we have a
holiday where we just beat up white
people
i wish you would come out here i don't
know what that's like
yo we so in hawaii the first couple
times that i went there there was a
group of
college football students from like
idaho or iowa some one of the really
just you know
white states yeah and they were coming
around and they were jumping out
and it was at this area called hanauma
bay hanama bay is a tourist spot but
there's stun locals that still go there
they were like trying to do pranks
unlike some of these like older asian
ladies or whatever whatnot that were
there
bro that [ __ ] was a rap real fast bunch
of big ass hawaiian dudes walked up and
they're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
literally this dude choked this guy and
hanama bay is like a cliff
yeah right and then this folk choked
them and put him to the edge he goes i
will literally toss you off this thing
i was like oh my god this place is the
promised land
you know i made it this is amazing and
this dude was like whoa it was just a
joke as they always say yeah
yeah and then but these dudes were not
[ __ ] having it and it was just like
seven big ass hawaiian dudes like i will
[ __ ] and these guys are all football
dudes and then i'll [ __ ] all you
but i'm afraid of like going to a play
like i don't
get why people go to foreign or places
they've never been and just start
doing [ __ ] no i don't they don't watch
title
they don't watch it locked up abroad i
do yeah i'm not [ __ ] with that
i'm not i'm not going to another country
acting crazy no
i'm when i get there i'm asking hey what
should i do what can you tell me where i
don't need to go
i don't know i don't need to be locked
up abroad i can't speak the language
they gonna [ __ ] me worse than being it's
bad enough being in prison
but being in a prison you don't speak
the language you don't know who plotting
on you
i don't know you just gonna get
what's going on in there i'll never
forget one episode locked up abroad it
was in i think
baghdad or something and you know this
is like in the height of it so this
american dude come in there
and they tell them it's going to be bad
they keep telling all right it's going
to be bad for you in there
so he gets there they're walking him in
he starts ripping off the sleeves of his
shirt
wrapping around his hands cracking his
neck because he know he got a fight
they said you're going to fight your way
to your cell his cell is upstairs
i'm telling the dudes all of them are
just out
just waiting for him he said the only
thing that saved them is that these men
aren't really that big these are just
regular like
you know they're malnourished and [ __ ]
so he's just in there as soon as he
comes he just punching
punching he was a fighter he was a
fighter he's just punching his way he's
getting hit too but he just keeps
he just keeps moving punching whoever
didn't wait a movie fights all the way
through downstairs
upstairs gets his cells and closes it
and they say they left him alone
no no not yet not yet so then his whole
time there
no they didn't like him he's american
they don't [ __ ] with him so they ain't
not liking him but it was one person
that no one [ __ ] with it was this
um ceo this correctional officer like he
made life hell for everyone especially
the american dude
but one day the american dude i think
beat him up or something
and got him kicked out of the jail they
celebrated him after that
never had an issue again they loved him
for getting that ceo
out of that prison like they treated him
like a king after that
what that [ __ ] was what i remember
that's like when you let me see how many
people
my man had to fight all the way up the
stairs up the stairs
and he's getting hit but he's just
punching back he said they were bigger
and stronger
he wouldn't have made it yeah that's the
only thing that helped him that they
were much smaller and weaker
that [ __ ] so i was like i don't have
time to be locked up abroad i'm not i
can't do prison
i can't do it right now i'm not i'm not
doing it no
it's funny i only saw one episode it was
like they were in south america and i
just couldn't watch the show anymore
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life some jails the prisoners run
it like they
have weapons in there it was the one in
south america the prisoners were running
the whole thing and the guards are just
on the outside they're like this is just
a city
and you have to live here in this [ __ ]
city so that dude had to
first thing he had to do for a whole
month was just clean up [ __ ]
and piss all day and you gotta do it
they'll stab you up they had shanks they
had like their own weapons
and it was like nobody was gonna take it
away from them because prison was just
you live in this [ __ ] city
yeah i can't believe that went through a
[ __ ] prison in baghdad and got mopped
up
by eight thousand people but he held it
down
he didn't fall all the way to his cell
i had a buddy of mine who went to uh uh
he was i mean if i if i introduced you
to this dude you would never think he
went to prison
the guy's the nicest dude he's actually
one of my business partners mm-hmm but
he went to prison and he was talking
about drinking usually make the best
business part
he doesn't take no for an answer so this
dude told me that he went to prison
uh for about a year uh i think it was
for like jacking homes or some [ __ ] like
that right
the first thing that you have to do he
says you have to align yourself with
a crew and it's always by race so you
see the asian people you got to go with
the asian people
but he goes either way you're still not
safe because you're their [ __ ] so what
they were doing for the whole time
i he i think he was in there for a year
or less i forgot how long it was but
basically they used it for cockfighting
so it's like this dude
is gonna have to fight some other new
dude that's in the prison every time a
new person for their entertainment for a
year
before he had to do that and so his
first fight before he came up i think it
was like
i don't know how he avoided it but he
had one fight that was coming up and
they would make him do push-ups every
day they would train him to fight
so they could [ __ ] this other person
that's coming in literally the day
before that he has to fight them
fight fight the other inmate he gets uh
let out
so he never had that he's never had to
do oh man he said it was
[ __ ] rough because like you had to be
somebody that you're not just to survive
can't do that dude and that's my thing i
always say if i did
just adapt that life i'm gonna be a
criminal i'm taking all the self-defense
classes i'm learning how to fight back
because kickboxing and everything
because if i know at some point i may
end up in here
and i want to be able to defend myself
is
that'd be so funny like prisoners are so
different now they're like what's wrong
with this guy
bro you got 30 years there was another
show i watched where this guy
he was falsely accused of murder
and then led out of prison now he goes
to different prisons and just like
showcases it
he went to one prison i forgot where
some cold climate
this was the best prison i've ever seen
my life they had a grocery store they
had their money on cards
was this in sweden it might have been it
might believe so
communal couches with the guards the
guards will be sitting like we sit and
talking to the prisoners
they're cooking i'm like this is the
best if i got to go to send me this
let me over there they got a grocery
store no one steals kill i'll kill
somebody right now
if that's my life i'll murder somebody
right now send me there
because sweden's sweden's prison
reformation is about reformation
yeah so a buddy of mine he's chinese
swedish and he was telling me about the
prisons
and he showed me like a picture of what
a prison cell looks like it looks like
an ikea yeah
like i'm not even making a joke like
it's like bed
tv desk computer and
and then when you come out the
government well it's a socialist country
so when you come out you just go to the
government they give you a job the next
day yes yes
so they're about reformation and some of
these people are so violent you wouldn't
think
they were so nice like what you're in
for murder
there's people in here these tennis
crimes but they just seem so nice that's
like if you're gonna do some crime just
go to sweden i'm talking about lady ceo
sitting with the guys yeah
well my [ __ ] uh my uncle was a
teacher
at folsom prison it's one of the hardest
[ __ ] prisons you'll ever see
this i got stories for days about this
guy too he's he the way
i remember this whole says some of the
most racist [ __ ] i've ever heard in my
life but he doesn't even know his race
is because he's just he's in a prison
home yeah yeah
so my cousin was a b-boy and he had this
other dude that was a b-boy i think he
was like like
colombian and black or some [ __ ] right
no he wasn't he wasn't he wasn't but he
was he was uh he was like colombian he
was like some kind of south american
country right
he just looks at this he looks at them
he goes
so you my son's a friend he goes yeah he
goes so what are you he goes like i'm
collabing he goes
it's a lot of you in prison so he just
walks out the place
what the [ __ ] was that a lot of you why
would you say that bro
come on man read the room bro
i was the friend funniest image dude
this was eating a bowl of ice cream he
just stops eating you know
it's like yo uncle say that to me i'm
like i don't know bro i don't even want
to be in that environment around that
energy to be honest like i like to help
people but if i had to yeah but i
wouldn't choose okay
this is my job that's a lot of energy to
bring home and just be in there
that's a lot like i can't even be around
negative people like yes i definitely
can't do that
like you do you feel like as you gotten
older you become more
like straightforward with how you feel
and say things to people yeah
yeah yeah you want to be completely
honest yeah yeah i don't want to beat
around the bush and let you know you
just tell
but the funny thing if i have to get
that honest i'm probably not going to
really [ __ ] with you
yeah that means your energy's off
already if i got to be that honest guy
well man unless they unless it's your
close friend they're going through
something like all right look
you [ __ ] up man like you know but
yeah somebody that you don't really know
even my friends when they talk about
their problems to me now i'm like i got
time for this bro
you old figure that [ __ ] out get it
together yeah get it together one of the
best things that he
taught me you've heard thing about when
people do call you well my homeboy is
like when somebody called you said now
because you know people call you they
just start venting and you bla you know
they don't ask you if you even do
anything he said
when they want to talk you say do you um
do you need my head my ears or my heart
on my heart
and i was like damn that's really good
because if you need my head
i can give you just my opinion if you
need my ears i just listen if you need
my heart i'm gonna give you compassion
empathy where you may be like
so it takes like okay what do they want
do you want advice
but if you ask that uh above they like i
just need your ear oh i just gotta sit
here listen i can play video games maybe
i was like oh [ __ ] whatever that makes
sense because i need my heart now okay
let me really pay attention let me give
you my undivided if you just need my
head let me give you some advice yeah i
started realizing there's like people
who kind of like
these are the people that i started
cutting out it's like people who use you
as like their emotional tampon
they just like you know what i'm just
gonna dump all my [ __ ] on you just
because you're available
it's like bro what this is a i think all
relationships are give and take you know
friendships are developed over time
because
you guys lift each other up mm-hmm well
i'm always dragging you up
like and eventually like you just start
drowning me and
that's what i started realizing with
certain friends it's like oh i'm just
here to help you
but when i need help you're not
available because you actually don't
have the resources to help me at all
so now it just feels like i'm a parent
and that started becoming super
exhausting
and i started to realize those people
too are also the ones that are very
they just aren't grateful for anything
that they have in their life because
there's like real complaints but there's
also solutions i'm not here to give
people solutions anymore
i don't do that [ __ ] the reason why is
because i feel like if you're a smart
enough person you can
figure it out you just need somebody to
listen to that's why you ask people
questions you don't tell you say
well why are you doing it or how are you
doing and then people usually start
they'll start to tick
after that they were like oh well i just
figured it out well done
you already had it but i'm just you know
i'm just healthy to someone to bring it
out yeah i used to be terrible at this
[ __ ] i have a buddy of mine who does a
podcast with me every now and then he
was telling me it's like
because i remember when i was trying to
tell you about my my my girlfriend
problems right
and like yeah she was an [ __ ] but you
went straight to the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
believe her
but that's the advice we give is young
dudes
you were right but i just want somebody
to listen to me
she was an [ __ ] i was like yeah i was
like that's how i was like
and i'm i'm trying to find that really
good balance of not
being that person it was hard though
because that's how you see how my mom
talked to me
that's how i speak you know yeah all
right the [ __ ] time like when i don't
like some
one of my friends just wish this for the
first time because usually we keep our
circles small but we met somebody knew
i didn't like and we were hanging out i
looked at this person i was like
i don't like you i liked it oh that's
funny
they're like they got really quiet i
thought you were joking and she was like
david
until i just looked without blinking and
he was like oh [ __ ] you really are like
that i was like yeah you're being really
obnoxious like you need to tone it down
like read the [ __ ] room the person
stopped talking
because i just didn't want to deal with
that yeah that's pretty much it
i just didn't want to deal with it
because it's like i gotta be here for
the next three hours you're gonna keep
saying inappropriate [ __ ] so
shut the [ __ ] up yeah some people are
too much some people believe that yeah
that person probably could have beat my
ass but i didn't call my bluff though
[ __ ]
that's what i thought my uncle works at
the prison can i uh use the bathroom
oh yeah go ahead okay i'm just making
sure i didn't want to uh we bout to wrap
up anyways go ahead
hit the bathroom hey but [ __ ] wrong
though right
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] how did he
respond after that though like they were
just kind of like leave
no they just they he stood there and
just just watched
right because everybody wanted to say it
but i had to say it because nobody would
because he was just trying to be so
funny to the point where it was
obnoxious he was saying like some
inappropriate [ __ ] to the girls in the
group too
yeah he's like trying to be like that
type of funny and he just got to the
point where i was like
i'm too old for this i got to let you
know this because you're being [ __ ]
annoying
and nobody wants to deal with this we're
all in our 30s here [ __ ] you
you apologize afterwards no he was just
too embarrassed
he just i mean he wasn't going to
apologize because he didn't feel like he
did anything wrong
but it's just like when somebody staring
at you
like literally just looking into your
soul either two things were going to
happen he was going to buck back at me
fight me or he's gonna shut the [ __ ] up
so i'm assuming he never came out with
y'all again after that oh no
[Laughter]
absolutely not he got in the car man
[ __ ] that guy no
but that's what happened everybody was
because so uh our friend brought that
dude in
and then he was complaining to math he's
like yo you [ __ ] boy is all
disrespectful and [ __ ] blah blah blah
you know like oh he thinks he's like
some hot [ __ ] it's like nah bro he's
like
he's like that's how david is though
it's like you were annoying people we
just don't say anything
it's like you know you were kind of
making inappropriate jokes to the women
in the group
he didn't like it so he said something
he's like you're not going to get away
when you talk to david like that
did you the dislikes on your videos go
up after that
where's the [ __ ] guy he owns those
seven accounts
it feels good though it's like now like
i mean i've been like this for a good
chunk of my life but now i really don't
care
what's if you're insignificant to me i
don't care what your opinion about me is
anymore
it doesn't matter like in my mind you
did something wrong
and i you know people were uncomfortable
you didn't
read the [ __ ] room people were trying
to tell you so somebody had to say
something
and i just you know it's the problem is
too is like a lot of people have small
town
vibes about stuff like this small town
stuff is like everybody knows everybody
so they don't say [ __ ] they just kind of
let people do whatever they want
i don't really have that so every time i
like sometimes go back home and i'm
hanging out with certain friends there's
people in the group that everybody
dislikes but they always invite them
mm-hmm they ask they'll be like yeah
stop doing that yeah but then i'm always
the [ __ ] because i gotta tell this
dude to shut the [ __ ] up every time
because nobody else
nobody else will or it's gonna be the
most awkward time for the next six hours
it's like we're not doing that
we have to do this like you didn't have
to invite this [ __ ] here you
don't even like him
why you keep doing it but it's because
they don't for some reason they feel
like they need everybody's approval
still yeah
well if he walks away and he hates us
i'm going to feel bad it's like
who cares like he'll live he'll survive
he'll be [ __ ] fine we had a holiday
party not too long ago we were doing the
zoom call [ __ ]
this [ __ ] bro this is what i'm
talking about
some people feel a certain way i'm not
sure if you guys ever felt this were
because you guys uh accrued a certain
amount of success
they feel that they're either owed some
of your success
or they [ __ ] hate you for being
successful and it comes out in the most
sideways [ __ ] ever
and i just can't stand that stuff
because i'm always congratulating all my
friends
no matter what their successes are
because it's amazing to see yeah so
we're all chilling and [ __ ] and this
dude
literally comes up out of nowhere he
goes like oh so when you gonna cut me a
check for stealing all my jokes
this is like high school friend right
and i'm like when have you ever been
funny
and then everybody's like dead quiet i
was like no seriously he's like yeah
oh he goes like oh like that he said
you're just going to not give us credit
for anything like that i was like
i was like do you still work at a
sephora selling women's makeup
just what credit do you deserve i was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
are you still working at the same part
time and i just kept roasting them over
i was like you look like you [ __ ]
warm your hands over a burning garbage
can
[ __ ] out of you bro and they just very
well if you saw the way he looked i'll
show you a picture he looked like he
looks he kind of looks like
a will smith's dad that left him like
wasn't that [ __ ] that's one of the
best episodes
yeah if you didn't cry watching that you
soulless yeah
not for sure that episode man it's great
but you know
let me what's funny to me i'm not very
emotional
but i think one of the saddest cinematic
scenes
he always laughs like this it's when
[ __ ] dave chappelle is roasting nutty
professor
that [ __ ] is the saddest [ __ ] to me
because i never like bullies you know
i don't like being people like [ __ ]
kid
every time he said i laugh i was like
that's the sad thing man
he sees death that [ __ ] is so when you
look at the
look on his face and they play the music
i feel so
bad i guess i was playing
and then when you drop uh jada pinkett
off and she's like i'm sorry sherman he
like oh it's all right miss birdie
and then he walked he turned around got
the newspaper on his head he just
dropped it i felt
so every time it feels terrible
like the faces eddie was making like
when they started drowning it out and he
just
there's a lot of movies on the way
sorry for me you know ricky died when he
got hit with that shotgun 80 miles away
i love that movie it didn't make me it's
like man that's part of the hood
hey like what he kind of deserved why do
you split why are you taking the time
every day come on man every time you
tell me that i laugh that [ __ ] be so
funny watch it again this watch that's
it's the saddest [ __ ] well i know that
scene because i was fat and i didn't
say it but then at the same time i was
like kind of fat
what's funny i'm not very emotional but
i'm very empathetic i get that from my
mom so i just felt it for him and i
i used to like fight bullies in
elementary and stuff i didn't like
bullies
yeah like i didn't like it i don't know
white people i cried this morning
why i was on a walk and i had so much
gratitude
but you [ __ ] man
i was like crying
i listened to the church music i was
like why am i i'm crying no
i picked the pedal off the floor this is
god's creation
rub the pedal between his fingers and
smelled it oh my god
since he went there i got to flip it a
little bit like we've been in a pocket
this month
like the energy my frequency has never
been this high and it started with
um our friend gave us this prayer
affirmation it's four minutes
you do in the morning he says him and
his brother been doing it you do it
every day he said when they started
doing his brother won a grammy
his other business took off i was like
let me let me give me something
give it to me i'm all for stuff like
that kid you not
after i do it the next day booked the
show
hooked another writing gig i was like so
i kept doing it
more things kept popping up i'm like all
right all right hold on but it gets you
in this space you do it first thing in
the morning you're just so grateful and
you're putting this energy out
and it just works and then like i be
listening to other affirmation music
high frequency
music in the morning i always like to
set my tone because like your first five
minutes dictates your whole day for the
most part so
i got a whole morning routine because a
lot of times i feel like it's a choice
like sometimes you can wake up in a bad
mood yeah
but i can switch that mm-hmm if not
you're gonna be in a bad mood all day
and i don't like being like that so i
need
even as far as just making your bed like
yeah first accomplishment of the day
make my bed
dude personal responsibility is
something that a lot of people don't
like to hear
it actually makes them angry oh yeah
when you go hey you know i'm not i'm not
talking about very specific
negative i'm talking about stuff like
that like you're moving it was like well
you have an ability to change well [ __ ]
you i don't it's like
but if you're not taking responsibility
for how you feel your whole life is
going to be [ __ ]
yeah i always tell people this too it's
like you know
life is always about tripping like
you're tripping constantly we're all
we're all unbalanced human beings and
we're just trying to stand up all the
[ __ ] time
if you're not ready to take on what what
that is then
life is going to be tough because you
expect it to be nice to you all the time
it's not supposed to be that way life is
constantly beating you down it's about
how you react
yeah something's gonna happen just about
how you react i'm not definitely not
just walking outside and crying bro but
it's so bad
because your neighbor with the blinds
i'm like yo [ __ ] it was it was one
singular
[ __ ] oh my bad you got the glory to you
his
i'm very particular about my energy who
i let around me who i like to be around
like my frequency i just noticed like i
think certain blessings come on a
certain frequency
and when i started doing the affirmation
and getting deep in in
my morning routine start getting blessed
and like the energy that's been crazy
the people we've met and
a lot of people we go around they be
like man i like you guys energy i'm like
thank you i mean
just but that's why we you know
i mean that's that's the crazy i think a
lot of people always wonder this too
when they talk about this podcast like
i've always talked about i keep friends
for a very long time a very long time i
have the same friend since elementary
school
yeah you know and uh when when people
see a lot of other people like videos or
whatever i'm like
well those are acquaintances these are
friends they're they're different
you know what i mean and so like for you
guys too like
you guys been in the group for how many
[ __ ] years it's kind of nuts and
people always ask this too they go how
do you keep lasting friendships
what was your guy's answer to that well
it was a foundation before it was a
business so
we came all together organically and
then the way we came together it almost
seems like it was meant to be like i was
telling you how
i met him first day of school then he
was my neighbor then across from his
house a man i mean dorm emmanuel's room
was right there so it was like
how we this is like a 10 story building
how we all on the same floor
neighbors went together and then we just
just met up and linked so it felt like
it was more meant to be
and mike best friend sixth grade chess
my brother so it was like
this organic match it wasn't like we're
put together like day 26
we were friends before we started a
business so like the end of the day is
it's a friendship that uh business
derives i think it's an authenticity
thing too like you're only gonna
be around people who you can genuinely
feel like you'll feel when you're around
somebody like
i'm not gonna get along with them you're
like you you just know it like you're
like i'm the type of person
not gonna hang with them but so when you
find people who are just genuine and
authentic you're like
okay okay i can i can i can i can rock
with that you know
that relationship uh development part is
hard for a lot of people
yeah and sometimes i don't know how to
explain it like
you know we i talk about this concept of
uh when people move to big metropolitan
cities i always say like people even
when they're fresh if they [ __ ] on the
first date
they see a glimpse of what they like in
a human being and they go
that's my boy we best friends he's like
you don't even know
this [ __ ] and then they get
either backstabs something happens
i can't believe they did how you didn't
know them you did there's no foundation
you guys didn't go through [ __ ] dirt
and grime together
there is you have not seen this person's
true character that happened to me once
in my life and i never let it happen
again
and that was my fault i had to take
responsibility for that yeah because i
thought he was a good person because
this person was likable but likable does
not make you a good person
yeah it just makes you somebody
entertainer yeah an entertainer which
means you're an extrovert
so like people like even this guy too
like he he owed me a project
and we were friends for a couple of
years i helped him out a lot
and i was like oh like if we do a paid
project like he's going to get it done
in time
[ __ ] ignored my calls for like days
right
and he didn't know i had a short temper
at the time because that was super nice
but he owed me money oh yeah when you
broke
money is everything oh yeah everything
and so literally i just called him i was
like bro
i know where you live if you don't show
up at my house in an hour i'm going to
[ __ ] you up
that's it and then she just texted me
back and he goes i'll be there
and i was like so you want me to call it
why are you going to take off
why i gotta come out of character for
you yeah like give me whatever exactly
so he comes through
and i'm like [ __ ] livid you know
and then i'm just like bro what the [ __ ]
is your problem because i had this other
project i was like i don't give a [ __ ] i
gave you money
like you owe me the project my thing is
just just communicate bro
or say something say something anything
you don't just [ __ ] bounce
he was a [ __ ] he was a ladder climber
so he sees something more opportune
he'll drop anybody and everybody whether
it's friend family mother father it
doesn't matter yeah
it's for him and that's who he is and
we met up not too long ago i haven't
seen him in years
he comes up to me goes hey man it's been
like we were at this function and he was
at a function
that his his uh fiance
was doing well at so he just he's
tackling onto his fiancee's success now
so whatever he's still doing this thing
he comes up he goes hey bro i just want
to say like i'm a different man
i want to apologize and i just hope you
could be friends again i was like
hey thanks for the apology but we're not
friends yeah what i told you last time
was to never talk to me
so you need to move and that's what it
is because you're still the same person
and you just feel bad like think about
apologies too that i that i really
believe that people don't understand is
like
when you give somebody apology you do it
because you feel like you did wrong but
it's still up to the person to forgive
you or not
like for me i don't think about you you
know
i have a choice not to think about you
but you're not coming into my circle
because that's what he's asking now
yeah he's like hey we could be friends
let's have lunch again now you're trying
to be in my circle
i'm not breaking bread with you you stay
outside exactly and you've seen how
people apologize in your household
so you know it really oh yeah yeah i was
like i don't see you bleeding from you
guys yeah yeah
you bleeding bro you need to apologize
yeah you better rip out your eyelashes
or something and put it down on that
sacrifice out here yeah where's my goat
like put your finger on the plate
hand it to you i want to see that [ __ ]
oh yeah but hey man that wraps up this
podcast that [ __ ] was an hour and 40
minutes
so much [ __ ] to talk about but where can
they find you guys
oh man all right let's do the rundown
all right first and foremost at
dormtainment um youtube instagram
twitter uh find our uh sunglasses
business at the shadyside
up uh and shadysideup.com
tune into the comedy trap house where we
were gonna bring you some i'll never see
you wearing shades yeah i don't think
he's the same
guy i got these tiny ass eyes bro i just
went and i'm good
comedy trap podcast uh for our patreon
it's uh patreon.com backslash bosstalk
um and check us out on there and then
uh my instagram is at i roam a lot and
cam from dt and that's that's pretty
much pretty much it cool every thursday
and sunday we'll see y'all next time
peace